[Music]
hi guys we are now live from saint louis
i am
grand master roma eduard from france
and well this is my this is my first
stay in san luis as a resident gm
i've come here before come as a
commentator as a player as well
and now it's a pleasure to be here as a
resident gm and
trainer so
today's master class will be about
attacking
attacking masterpieces uh and very
strong external sacrifices
we will start with a game by kasparov
which is actually
the
easiest of the three
um he just won one of this typical night
off
say using a
queen's an extreme sacrifice that
nowadays
uh is well known to be to be to be great
for black anyway let's
pass on let's uh
go through the opening
uh quickly
i mean here um white
played queen f2
in order to
increase the pressure on the d file
so that uh
the d file is no longer covered uh by
the by the white queen
so there is a victory between uh the
rock and the queen e5 could come at some
point also this knight on b6 could be
hanging but kasparov solved this problem
playing the very natural knight fd7
which is anyway a move like plays in
that kind of position between because
white will push g5 at some point
so all you know queen f2 not only was
uh well let's say that first of all it
was pretty useless but after king b1
roxy8 it also turns out that the queen
on f2 is
highly misplaced because sec potential
sacrifices on c3 are coming
many years ago
engines were not that strong and
it took them quite a while to understand
that this
sacrifice that that kind of sacrifice is
pretty pretty strong for black because
it understands not only short-term
compensation but also long-term
compensation
so
that that is why a strong plan like maf
session
lost uh
last an easy game to
to kasparov session i mean of course
maleficent is not kasparov but as white
against kasparov is supposed to the game
is supposed to be a fight
nowadays of course any
any good engine in the show just just
shows that this kind of sacrifice is
great for black i see in the chat that
someone says this looks similar to a
casper of game but this is a casper of
game this is mob session against
kasparov played in the year 2000
so
white played bishop d3 here and now of
course
kasper of two counts is three
but he did not repeat the mistake
his colleagues had done in the past
because that position had already been
played but black had tried to
achieve
immediate
compensation
black tried to recover the material
immediately playing moves like knight a4
trying to
play against the c3 pawn and doing
everything just to reduce
uh
the
the material the material balance
but kasparov at the right up the right
approach playing can moves queen c7 now
knight a4 could definitely be a threat
because c3
would uh
would be impossible to defend
white played knight e2
and kasparov just played bishop b7 and
this is the right approach to this
position there is no concrete way to
checkmate
the white king white black is going to
obtain compensation
playing d5 and just playing against
the weakened white king and
the weakened pawn structure on the queen
side
but this is something i mean is not
going to check mate only with three
pieces attacking
the white king he needs all of his
pieces into the game i don't know why
this rock is
corroded
i don't know why there is a
circle there but whatever i
don't know if i can get rid of it looks
like a yes i can
so anyway casper of at the right
approach he just completed his
development because he understood that
he needs all of his pieces in the attack
white played g5 there is not much white
can do apart from
starting his attack on the king side it
is pretty clear that kasparov is going
to castle king's side i mean he can't
castle queenside anyway but his king is
not going to stay in the center it's
pretty clear kasparov wants his rock to
join the attacks so mob session starts
to push his pawns on the king's side
castles
h4
knight a4
maf system played
bishop c1
which is uh
which is a pretty
pretty natural move i would say
although perhaps not the best of course
is hoping for kasparov to take
everything on c3
after what
he will just take and put his bishop on
b2 and suddenly his king will be very
safe and his bishop on b2 will be very
strong targeting
the black king on the long diagonal so
of course
again
kasparov did not hurry
he continued increasing the pressure
played 95
white continued pushing his pawns king
side is king side king side pawns
d5
it's a casper of star now that all the
pieces are optimized
kasparov opens the position
queen h2 was played in the game that
that's probably not such a great move
but the position is anyway extremely
difficult to play
black just played bishop d6
and now the white king is the white
queen is having to move again
and here kasparov could have played
let's say a move like rogue ba trying to
push b4 and he would have enormous
compensation
but he decided to go for
a concrete approach
he took on these three which is a very
surprising move at first
as
the district bishop was not really
powerful
and
after the after after cd3 the white
constructor is
at least seems
much more solid than it was one move
before but he had a concrete idea in
mind
here he played b4
morris forcing white to take on d4
because you can't allow b takes c3
and c4 would not be great either you
just take
and uh
then for example
say d takes e4
queen takes e4
the bishop on d6 is hanging but the
knight on e2 as well and then the knight
will come to c3
b shall be five is a straight also some
sacrifices on e4 also b3 this would just
be hopeless for white
so
white took on b4
and now kasparov had a very concrete
continuation in mind he played rock c8
straightening queen c2
basically forcing a1
and now
comes the concrete tactics which is
often
which is often the way after and you i
mean after you after you
go for
the dynamic sacrifice like rock takes c3
you improve all of your pieces you open
the position and
the game ends with
a concrete tactics this is the way it
goes very often
players make the mistake to sacrifice
and then
immediately try to look for the concrete
tactics because they don't want to stay
so many moves and exchange down but in
this game kasparov had the right
approach from the start till the end and
now
oops sorry
only
and now only comes the concrete
tactics dxe4
pontex e4
and bishop ac4
a very strong sacrifice which white
cannot accept since after
bishop e5 check whitegate gets
checkmated he needs to put something on
d4 otherwise quincy two mates will would
come if the white king has to go to b1
but after bishop takes d4
rock takes d4 there is queen takes c1
and it's a mate
so that means after bishop takes e4
white cannot take
so out of desperation
i'm obsession played g6
kasparov simply took the material
on h1
queen h1
bishop takes b4 it's very clear here
that the white
king is going to be checkmated very soon
pantex f7
king f8 i'm not saying that uh
taking taking the pawn on f7 would be
bad but there is no reason to expose the
black king when you can just play king
f8 and allow zero contour play
queen g2 was played
rock b8
straightening simply bishop c3 check and
then queen takes his three
and the white the white king is just
trapped on a1 because of the b8 rock
white played bishop b2 here
knight takes b2
and knight d4 trying to mess things up a
little bit
with this knight xc6 threat
king takes b2 would just run into a mate
for example bishop d2 check
king a1
bishop c3
and so on knight
queen c3 and then checkmate
knight d4
here many moves were winning but
kasparov just went for the concrete
variation knight xd1 knight e6 king f7
white can take the queen
uh immediately or he can first
already confess or he can play queen
takes on the seven
king takes e6 queen takes is seven but
in either case bishop c3 check will come
and white will be left
with a lot of material done actually
with
almost normal actually white will remain
without any material on the board so
after king takes f7 white resigned so
that was a very easy victory for
kasparov a victory that you would not
see nowadays in a high-level game for
the simple reason that
all these all these things done now well
now i mean there is no strong players
uh there is no strong player like mob
session who would allow rock takes
history in such perfect conditions
because even
a regular engine is showing that
rocktech's history is immediately better
for black
but okay that was let's say some sort of
introduction to the action sacrifice
um how do we move to the next game i
would just exit out of that window okay
let's do that
oh that's the same one
oops i just go to notation
so
the second one is a game of mine
which well i would not dare to
compare to kasparov's game of course
but i thought it was nice to show it
right after the
right after the first game
because
basically what happened on the
queen side on in kasparov's game
happened
on the king side in my own game
so
obviously my
i will never say that my calculation was
as deep as kasparov's but
there are some similarities in a way
that uh i mean you will see when uh
when we will uh develop the we develop
the game so okay
this be this system uh the knight f6 i
like to play against uh
players with a slight
i mean worthless slightly
inferior rating to mine
it allows e4 that is a minus point but
okay d5
i react in the center
here cd5 and e5 is one knight this is
more of an equalizer
i mean here black can play for example
d takes e4 and knight f6 and then trade
many pieces this is known to be nothing
for white but on the other hand it is
nearly impossible to win that kind of
position with black
so i decided to keep the tension and
play knight e7
and again it's possible to trade
everything to take on e4 and knight c6
knight f5
to target the d4 pawn white will have to
push d5 at some point many pieces will
get exchanged and the game is
extremely likely to end in into a draw
so i decided to keep the pressure
with knight bc6 my opponent played
bishop e2
and i castled
my opponent castled as well
so now again i have this question should
i continue
uh keeping the tension in the center or
should i play d4 and knight f5 which is
some some sort of equalizer so i decided
to play b6 which is a little bit sharper
and see what my opponent wants to play
now it seemed to make sense for white to
take and play e5
i played and i played the knight f5
attacking the d4 pawn knight b1
so that may look like a weird move but
white simply wants to
relocate the knight to c3 which is
perfectly logical
i played f6
so i don't know why this is
colored so i react in the center i mean
now that my opponent has
pushed his piece pieces towards the
queen side
to react in the center is something
extremely logical
bishop b5 that's also very logical when
i take on e5 white one i mean first i
have to protect my knight obviously but
the bishop on b5 is very useful because
when i take on e5 white wants to be able
to take on c6 and put a knight on d5 and
this is what i did in the game and at
first it might look like suddenly white
is doing very well because it has a very
strong knight on d5 the problem is that
i'm going to play c5 next and white will
be unable to
keep a solid center and if i manage to
break the century feminist to eliminate
this d4 pawn and then push d4 myself
then my bishop on b7 will be a monster
tonight on e5 won't be well placed
anymore and the position will definitely
turn
to my to my favor
so
here my opponent played queen d2
i played c5 obviously
knight f3 back
because white
definitely doesn't want to take on c5
after bc5 d4 would come so white is
ready to anything
to keep
d4 protect protected so i can't open the
diagonal of my bishop
here i played knight d6
so i have several ideas one is to
sacrifice on f3 which is why i was
sort of comparing this game to the
previous one
because the previous one was a
an action sacrifice against
white's long castle and here we have an
action sacrificed against white's short
castle
also my knight on d6 is quite well
placed it might jump to c4 or to e4 on
the next move it's also difficult to
find a good way to defend the knight on
f3
for example
industry have bishop a6
winning an exchange the same applies to
queen e2 if queen is three i have knight
c4 winning time on the queen
and there are also some problems with
the v2 pawn
so it is difficult for white to do
something in the game i thought this was
the best thing to do but okay i would
take and play knight f5 and then d4
and again
i have
i i will have activa i will have i mean
i i will get
the the best i can dream of
from this position my bishop after d4 my
bishop on b7 will be extremely strong
putting pressure on the g2 pawn the
knight might if jump to h4 the queen
might come to d5
this would be a very unpleasant thing to
deal with as white
so
my opponent played rock 81 here
and of course this is our subject day
i took on f3
and played queen f6 so i can't move
i need my queen in the attack
let's remove this arrow
and in my queen in the attack and i'm
asking a question to my opponent do you
want to take on c5 but then d4 might
come at any moment opening the diagonal
of my bishop which might now turn
quiet uh
quite disastrous for white if my queen
comes to f3
so let me have a look at the chat
okay no big question so far
so queen f6
and my opponent
took on c5
so for example that would be bad because
after knight f5 i would come the knight
would come to h4 with check and that
would be quite disastrous for disasters
for white
i've been thinking of knight e2 with the
idea of playing queen f4 next for
example quintex f3 queen f4
uh the knight on e2 is hugging but the
knight on d6 as well and white can dream
of
holding the position but i think knight
f5 is just strong i want to play knight
h4
if the queen comes to f4 then i have
tactics like this one
attacking the knight on e2 is check so i
can't just play queen takes queen as i
would take on e2 intermediary
um
if something like that then i have
knight xd4 probably but also knight h4
which is maybe
which could easily be stronger because
quintex f3 is
another threat here
and that would
go back go bad
for for white as well
so melbourne took on c5 and now we have
a very concrete position
um
i have to take it i have to make a
decision here
i can't take on c5 but then after knight
takes d5 i it's something concrete
i can't take on
f3 but then after queen e3 i might just
help my opponent
defending his position as a queen is
going to come as defender to g3
and well i have
well i have a concrete problem as well
it is pretty clear that i have
compensation but i have a clear problem
to
deal with and this can only
be solved with extremely concrete
calculation
so i've been thinking for a while
and after some time i realized that this
was a winning continuation
queen d6 check followed by d4
other moves for example i mean this
for example
would not work for black
queen h5 for example
um attacking the pawn on f3 so knight e7
for example just king somewhere and
the pawn on f3 is a big problem but
after
okay king g2 maybe knight f5 is
dangerous because of knight g4 knight h4
coming but after king g1 i could not see
what i could do i mean of course i can
make a draw with queen g6 but i did not
see anything better
if i take then the queen comes to f4
and after bishop takes d5 at the end of
the day
i'm losing
uh i'm losing my knight and white
remains with an extra exchange and of
course a winning endgame
so
that was not very i mean that was not
very
that was not what i wanted let's say i
saw that this this was i considered this
as a draw
um i was calculating d4 of course
because after queen takes queen f3 it
for at first it might look like white is
in big trouble but white just plays
knight d5
and there again i could not find
anything else also queen f4 should be
possible here but even queen takes c5
and well i would i would
not have anything better than a draw
um i don't know why i did not mention
the move queen f4 here
uh which is similar to the previous
position if not exactly the same
uh that should be even stronger than
queen takes c5 but anyhow
it was clear that after d4 and quintex
f3
there was no way
the position could be winning for black
and after some calculation i realized
that this was very strong
now queen takes d4 is not an option
because of bishop f3 mate
of course i could not do that before
i mean if i could first play d4 and then
queen g6 check that would be a dream but
there is queen g4 that is a problem
so that's the reason why i played queen
g6 first and then d4
now knight e4 is absolutely forced
since this is just made in one
and after 94
i considered
two moves which i i
which i considered the both are as
winning
uh i actually was
leading to
very similar winning and games
one was simply well first actually i
considered three moves because this is
also very good i mean i have now i keep
now i am keeping my d4 pound
the knight on e4 cannot move because of
bishop takes f3 i definitely have
enormous compensation here
um
probably winning compensation even so
that was uh that was
one of the possibilities like that let's
say that was a backup possibility if i
couldn't find a concrete win but i
thought there was there were two
concrete winds one of them being knight
xe4
so there are some weird arrows there um
but okay let's just ignore them
uh queen taxi fortec
f3
queen f5
if i can play b if i if i can play b
take c5 then i'm
doing very well
and there
in that position i thought white is just
going to
suck the exchange back and i couldn't
see anything for black
so
actually
i thought there was a second win here
which i
which i had considered
knight takes e4
bishop takes e4 is f3
maybe i am wrong um
maybe the two moves i was hesitating
with uh were bc5 and queen f5 simply so
queen f5
threatening queen takes f3 and it's very
difficult for white to
defend the spawn in a clever way for
example
um queenie i mean this is just knight
takes e4 and it's very important that i
have i can check check and then take on
e4 and now it's a checkmate
if queen e2
then i would just take and
that would be a huge improvement to
compared to btx5 right away
knight takes d6 is still impossible
because of
bishop takes f3 but now bishop a6 is
coming as well rocky 8
and the queen's being placed on f5 and
e2 is definitely an improvement for
black here black would be completely
winning
so
i considered queen queen d3 which is the
move of the game as critical
again bc5 is definitely a good option
it's like
it's like the backup once again
but i decided to go for a concrete
variation pawn takes e4
so this is just
winning for black so white has to give a
check and actually now i remember why i
was
uh i mean why there were two concrete
lines
i was thinking about actually i was
wrong about the moment of the game while
it was played
in 2016 so that was
six years ago so you should forgive me
for
uh for not
remembering uh everything
so it's here that i was strongly
hesitating when i was killing i was
calculating all this in advance
obviously i thought
that bishop d5
as a as i played in the game was an easy
option
white has to take on e4
queen takes e4
f3
and now i just recover the material
and this should be a completely winning
endgame
i will come with my king to e5
i have a majority on the queen side a
majority of the under king side
this is just hopeless for for white as
you will see
um
however i was also considering king f8
in that position
which is a funnier line
takes takes white needs to go f3 and
after bishop d5
the queen has to go to d3 because this
is just game over
if king e1 king g1 queen g4 then queen
g2 that would be a checkmate
and rocktax f3 now is not just uh
giving an exchange back it is also
losing the other rock on d1
so queen d3 is absolutely forced here
and i can again play
a very similar rocket game the
difference being that the e4 pawn is now
on f3
so i was calculating for a while
but i simply thought that uh
besides being more
besides being simpler i thought that
decent game was actually a better choice
simply because the pawn on e4 is an
easier first of all is an easier target
since i can try to bring my king to e5
but also as there is no pawn on f3 have
a majority on the queen king side
so i simply judged this end game as
easier
than the previous one
so this happened in the game and here my
opponent understood that he cannot just
play random moves he has to do something
concrete if he wants to save the game is
not in time for b4 i will just take and
play rock b8 then the
rock will have to be very defensive and
i'll bring my king to e5 and this is
completely
over
so instead my opponent tried roxy one
and i simply played roxy8 i want to push
my pawns c4 d3 and so on or just bring
my king
roxy 4 because my opponent's only chance
to save this game is to play b4 but you
can't do it now i would just play c4 or
first a b4 and then c4
so he's trying to block c4 and he wants
to play b4
but now the concrete wind arrives
d3 roxy went back
and i went for rock b8 i mean many
things should win here but rock b8 is
sort of precise if roxy 5 i play d2 rock
takes b2 and then rogue b1 check and d1
queen
of course king g2 to to avoid rock b1
check is even worse because i will play
d1 queen and that will be an entire
extra queen
so here my opponent has to play rock d1
c4
i'm straightening rock takes b2 putting
an end to the game so rock d2 has to be
played and again everything wins here
but i went for the concrete way with
rock takes b2
takes c3 and here my opponent resigns
because he can give couple of checks but
they only help me bring my king closer
and then i will play c2 d2 and i'm going
to
queen one of my pawns capture the rock
with
the queen that will
be promoted so this is
game over
so
now you understand the
similarity of sacrificing and actions
against the opponent's king
one question
yes
instead of rook c4 when he had just
played like king g2 and just tried to
walk his king closer
i don't think i would rush pushing my
pawns i think i would just bring my king
first
if he wants to i mean if if he wants to
just play around the moves
uh
that will be
in a way favorable to me because i'm
very happy to bring my king to e5 and my
king will help me push my pawns easier
and i don't really see how white is
going to do something you can play roxy
4 at some point
um
so actually here maybe you're right that
uh
that that if i'm given a chance to play
c4 i should do it i mean why not
i mean
here this is just i mean this here this
is just completely hopeless this rear
seat
needs to be closer yeah
so i think
yeah i think here king g2 would make
more sense but then maybe i would start
with rock b8 just to see what white
wants to do with his rock and to avoid
any kind of
b4 and then i would start bringing my
king
and i do not see i mean white will never
manage to push b forever and if he
doesn't then the position is just
lost i mean i bring my king to e5 if
i if i want like first of all i have
some rock b3 or i can push c4 but if
even if i don't find a concrete win on
the queen side on the king side i can
play g5 g4 h5 even if i sacrifice one
pawn there
and then take e4
then my d-pawn will just go to
promotion
uh
without
without further
calculation
so
any more question
okay
so
well actually the last game is the most
complex one
uh but as we have just some 20 25
minutes uh
we are going to
oops
we are going to go to the crusher moment
of the game
that was
as that was a slav difference with a6
which is one of kamsky's specialties i
mean i played against kamsky
well there were blitz games but i played
against kamsky
no more than a few months ago and he was
still playing this slide with a6 that
just played all of all of his life you
know
so
he definitely likes this opening
although i find it a bit passive for for
black but he it he does like it very
much
so this is how the game developed so i i
may point out that bishop g5 is a very
useful move
why because in this position
when black plays e5 and everything gets
exchanged on e5 the pawn on h6 would be
hanging the other reason for including
bishop g5 and h6
here it's also
also important to mention that knight c3
is a very clever positional idea and
there is a very simple explanation to it
there is only one good square for the
black knights which is d5
and black has two knights for his only
on the square
the other knight will remain bad and use
useless
so black's only chance is actually to
bring bring the other knight to d5 as he
did in the game to f8 and then to e6 is
7 d5
so it would be a huge improvement for
black to extend one pair of flight and
put the knight on d5 right away
here black has this problem
only one good square and tonight so why
to give him a chance to eliminate to
trade one of the knights
that's why toppolov played knight c3
let's look at the game from the white
side by the way
kamsky played rocky eight but he's still
not threatening e5
knight f8
well actually e5
now we could do
but then after takes takes knight a4
bishop f4 knight b6 is coming and black
is having very concrete problems as well
so kamsky went for this slow manner many
arrows but this time they make sense so
why black wants to put the knight to d5
going through
e6 c7 and then play bishop f5
and if feminine if he manages all this
in good conditions then his position
would be fine
queen b3 was
played knight is x
bish
excuse me bishop is three protecting the
four knights is seven
so white so black is being very close to
managing his goal 95
attacking f7 attacking possibly
attacking g6
knight d5
now white traded one pair of knights but
black lost so much time to achieve this
that it was time to
allow it
and because white did not want to give
the bishop pair away he played bishop d2
let's remove all of these arrows
um i probably hear from some previous
explanations i gave about the position
anyway here white wants to play rocky
one black has a concrete problem with
his b7 bone um and if he goes let's say
queen c7
to protect b7 and play bishop e6 or
bishop f5
well on f5 white will have g4 that don't
bring very that won't bring very much
and here after rocky one bishop e6 will
never be possible because of knight
takes g6
and so and there is no good discovery i
mean
in the worst case there would be a rock
take c6 on the next move if the if black
had a good
a good night move here but i don't think
he has because knight f4 is bishop takes
f4
so
black is sort of paralyzed here and the
only way kamsky found
that
to give his position some
some sense was to take on e5
and play h5 he has to play h5 because
his pawn is under attack
and if black can manage to play queen c7
and bishop b6
then his position is perhaps slightly
worse
white as a bishop pair
but black is extremely
solid he lost his fiance bishop but it's
very important for him that white has a
pawn on e5 so the long diagonal i mean
the a1 h8 diagonal can be can be open at
least as long as
there is a pawn on e5 so if if he
manages this which is queen c7 bishop b6
his position his position is playable
but here topolov
found a wonderful idea
which is to play rocky 1
so bishop b6 is too early because of
queen takes b7
black had to protect b7 first and now
topple off went for an action sacrifice
black took
and rogue takes c6
now you can see all these weaknesses
on the
black side
black would very much prefer that this h
5 pawn
stays on h7 but
it moved to h6 a long time ago
so there is no way it could
be there protecting the g6 pawn
topple of plate rocky one putting
pressure on one of the weaknesses
obviously the two weaknesses
are these two
queen d7
queen these three
putting pressure on the other weakness
king h7
rocky 5 attacking h5
knight f6
here rock takes h5 would not be very
clever i mean it would be a nice tactics
because of course pla g8 g85 is not a
legal move and knight h5 just allows
queen takes queen but after king g7
white would be very much announced
because he would have to trade queens
he would still have some compensation
for the actions but this is not what he
wants
so topolov played queen e3 trying to
well simply keeping queens
alive
threatening queen h6
so black was more or less forced to play
king g7 he did not want to remove his
knight
from f6 because then the bishop would
come to e4 and that would turn to a
disaster for black
king g7 was played
and here
actually shouted too fast
the only piece in the white position
that can be improved is the g2b shop and
this is
a very important strategical lesson in
general not only because
not only in the exchange sacrifice topic
but also in any kind of position
when you have improved when you when you
have when you have optimized almost all
of your pieces you need to ask yourself
what piece can i still improve in my
position
i mean if you have a concrete win here
it could very well be that why it has a
concrete wind but it doesn't have
so if you can't find a concrete win you
have to ask yourself
what more can i improve in my improving
my position here white should improve
the position of his g2b shop that is not
helping in the attack
the problem is that at first it looks
like it cannot go to e4 because we do
not want to trade this bishop
but bishop f1 to c4 and then trying to
go to b3 c2 to target the g6 pawn would
be extremely slow
but bishop fb4 at once just works
the thing is that black can't capture
this can't capture it because of
queen h6 jack and rock takes e4 and the
rock is coming to f4
queen h7 is also a strat and for example
rock g8 loses to queen h7 check followed
by rook f4 check so concretely speaking
there is no difference here for black
so
by calculating this pretty simple line
queen h6 and rock takes e4 topoloff
understood that he could get his bishop
to to the right diagonal right away
and now it's very clear that black is
under huge danger
with the g6 pawn being a clear target
for white
king f7 was played the sacrifices on g6
has not are not working yet
bishop c2
so you see the bishop came to c2 in just
two moves instead of one two three four
so that's a huge win of time for white
rock 88
queen h6 threatening bishop takes g6
that would lose right away because the
white rock would come to g5 and
you can say goodbye
and after rock g8 protecting the pawn
the d2 bishop has to move
so better move it somewhere where it
attacks something
now if black just plays some random move
the position is completely hopeless
after road g5 i mean the pawn on g6 is
lost
the bishop on a5 is useful because the
key the black king cannot even run away
bishop takes g6 we just recover the
material with an enormous advantage
practice was objectively the least
damage for black but
here material is equal look at the black
king look at the pawn structure this is
going wrong for black
so black decided
for queen d4 a concrete line
the bishop went back to c3 and again
just returning with a queen is not an
option because after road g5 the game
would be over
so
kamshi continued
let's say
uh let's say that he continued entering
the concrete variations
this looks very dangerous because of
bishop b3
but at least he's preventing the easy
move rogue g5 because now after knight
e4 it is why 2 could be in problems
this is no longer a problem because e6
is not under attack
and this king of fate
if king if queen h6 i'm not even sure
black wants to make a draw maybe even
runs to e8
and black has got what he wanted
keeping the queen on c4
so black needed to play this move queen
c4 so after the rock g5 he could play
knight e4 but now of course there is
bishop b3
queen d3 white already recovers one pawn
and he's already able to recover the
exchange and have equal material and an
excellent position but toppola wanted
even more he wanted to checkmate his
opponent
so he played king g2
which is a useful move because for
example bishop g8 would not be winning
at once because of
queen b1 check
rock d1
with some counterplay well actually
actually actually it would be quite good
but it would require some precise
calculation queen b1 rock d1
and now
black has some control play
but this would be a forced checkmate as
far as i remember
queen g7 check
and here bishop a5 is very important so
the king cannot escape to c8 and king e8
is queen f7 mate
so calculating all that
bishop g8 is also a very good move
because i i guess
uh knight g8
queen h7 doesn't leave black
many chances to to escape but anyway
topolov took it easy and just
decided for king g2
if white the difference is that if white
play if if black plays queen b1 with the
idea after bishop g8 to play the same
rock d1 although we saw that it doesn't
work because of frog e7
now white will play rocky one and in
case of if the if the black queen the
black queen moves now we take on g8 and
if rock d1
queen f4 is a very strong move
because queen b8 is basically
impossible to prevent on the next move
so here kamsky played rocket f8
queen g7
so
white is threatening things like
bishop f5
afterwards it will be impossible to
defend
both the e7 pawn and the black queen
black played rock d5 of course it would
be a dream for black if white would just
take on d5 then black would have a very
strong knight on d5 and everything would
be defended and suddenly even black
would
even have some would even have some
activity with queen f3 check
followed by checkmate being threatened
so this is definitely not what white
wants but bishop f5 still works here
rock f7 the only way to complicate
matters otherwise
i mean rock takes c5 bishop takes queen
and game over
and here topalov found the very precise
rock takes c7
this should also be winning
but rocky 7 is extremely precise here
black resigned because after
road after k7 this is just a forced
checkmate
and after rookie 7
this is also
completely over on the next move white
is going to capture
the black the black queen
so um
that was i think i mean
that was the true master class by by by
toppolov i mean
the wall the wall game is a true master
class
first
provoking h6
in order to slow down e5 from the black
side then keeping the knight so that
black needs a lot of time before he can
actually put a knight on d5
trading one pair of knights at the right
moment and then when black is just about
to consolidate his position with bishop
e6
e6 with an exchange sacrifice
up to now this is master class and the
master class does continue
white white attacks the weaknesses one
by one
then penetrates with his queen
finds this key move bishop before
winning a lot of time in the attack
since knight takes e4
just loses
bishop c2
queen h6
again based on precise calculation
bishop a5
bishops is three back and the rest was
let's say
pretty easy
if queen if queen somewhere we saw that
rock g5 was winning so black had to
prevent it after bishop b3 i would say
that this was pretty easy but double off
as i said did not hurry he played king
g2 very calmly and as i said every game
i mean
every perfect game every game
i mean topolof was definitely playing
for middle term long-term compensation
when he sucked this pawn in exchange
but
most of these games
do finish with the brilliant tactics
and in that in that case the brilliant
tactics was rocktake c7
um followed by a forced checkmate as i
show
showed before
um
so here we are
um i see as a comment that toppolov was
is a brilliant chess player i think most
people
know him for losing to kasparov
and
[Music]
well toppolov indeed is an amazing i
mean he is still an amazing player but
he is let's say semi-retired uh not to
say completely retired
um
but of course he is one of these players
who was always a pleasure to
watch because he's one of the
few players just like magnus carlsen who
never wanted to make a draw
he was sacrificing a lot so there isn't
complete i mean i mean he's very
different than magnus carlsen regarding
the playing style because magnus likes
to have a small advantage and just uh
show his opponent that he is a better
player toboloff is a different style is
putting all in all of his energy into
the game
just to calculate better than his
opponent and uh
win the game at the end of the day he
also likes to
take take risk by sacrifice i mean by
sacrificing by pushing his g pawn or his
h pawn or whatever
risky i was lucky enough to work with
him during four years i even wrote a
book about it which i called my magic
years with topalov so he's a good friend
of mine
um
and
working with him was just
was just incredible you know in any
position he was trying to sacrifice
something we were trying
i mean it was almost it was from 2010
till 2014 so
we started more than 10 years ago and by
then the engines were not so as strong
as now it was really possible to find
new ideas and he was really trying to
sacrifice things all the time
uh in every position trying to take risk
and uh
well
we we might we might see more of well
it's quite likely that we will see more
more of his games during my stay
is in san luis
because he's definitely a fascinating
players player and as we will
speak a lot about attacking chess uh
definitely we're gonna see
a few of couple of games
i think here we are for today
um
i hope you enjoyed the masterclass
although i feel like uh
as i'm still a little bit uh you know
with a time difference flying from
playing for france
i feel like i'm sometimes a little bit
a little bit slow or a little bit
confused but i hope anyway i was clear
in my explanations
and that uh and that you enjoyed the
games and explanations
and i will see you
well i think we have another
class is it perhaps not tomorrow
thursday
thursday we have another we have another
masterclass so we will see
more
excellent games
thanks for watching
thanks for your comments in the chat
sorry that i could not answer
all of the questions
and see you in two days
[Music]
you